thank you
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
but
[Music]
v
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back dear colleagues
bonjour
can i ask you
play
[Music]
[Music]
dear colleagues can i ask you
to play pony plus
wait while
this is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
refugees
is
the floor is yours
[Applause]
honorable members of the european
parliament
i feel here among the true friends of
moldova
in the circle of the family of our
people
allow me above all
to thank you on behalf of all moldovans
for your constant unwavering support of
moldova
and its european future
at good times
and at bad times
your support has been vital in keeping
moldova
on its democratic path
and supporting the aspirations of our
people
to live in peace
and prosperity
and to decide on our own future
thank you for this opportunity to
address you at a time when our region
and the world
is going through its most difficult
period in a long time
after the end of the cold war
expectations were high
among our newly independent states for a
new beginning
a new beginning of peace and development
which would relegate to distant past
unabashed land grabs and geopolitical
conquests by larger states
we all hoped that utter disrespect
for national borders
and the way of life chosen by newly
independent states would not recur
we expected that buffer zones
and spheres of influence would no longer
guide relations between neighbors
above all
we expected that states would be treated
as peoples with their own aspirations
and that their will and voice
will be heard
and respected
russia's war against ukraine
seeks to put an end to these hopes
and sends us all a century back in
history
this war
was caused precisely by geopolitical
designs to reshape the region
to divide it into spheres of influence
to cease territory
russia has attacked
a neighboring state
just as big powers did in the past
and has unleashed
an unimaginable tragedy on the ukrainian
people and the entire european continent
russia's war against ukraine was
designed
to turn ukraine
into something that nobody would want to
be
a geopolitical annex
of a more powerful neighbor
the baltic states
the bulgarians
the hungarians the posts the romanians
the czechs the slovaks and the germans
three states today
remember vividly
and all too well what this means
we had hoped
and expected that those times
would never return yet
they did
we all see with our own eyes
the tragedies of women
men children and elderly who lost their
homes and their loved ones
we all saw crimes against ukrainians
who did no wrong to anyone
moldova feels deeply the pain and the
tragedy that ukraine is going through
in the early morning of february 24th
moldova woke up to a new dream reality
like many in our country
i could hear the bombs
falling over odessa from my office
but the shock agony
and disbelief of the war
was met
by our citizens with kindness generosity
and
in
compassion
matter of a few hours our authorities
started receiving tens of thousands of
refugees fleeing the brutality of the
war
only in a few weeks
our population of 2.6 million people
increased by 4 percent
almost half a million ukrainians crossed
our border and around 90 000
people are still with us
hosted by my big-hearted fellow citizens
half of the refugees
today are children
and this constitutes 10
of the total number of children in my
country
we are overwhelmed but determined
to do our best to help those in need
we will continue to provide humanitarian
support to ukraine and will continue to
stand by the ukrainian people our
neighbors
our friends
our partners
we have immediately condemned
russia's war against ukraine
we support the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine as we
always did
crimea is ukraine
donbass is ukraine
kiev is ukraine
and they will always be
this war has no justification
and it must be stopped
immediately the last three decades
moldova has had many achievements
of which can we can be proud
throughout our independent history
moldova has been and remains a
democratic country with free and
competitive elections
freely expressed will and dignity of our
people is a fundamental value which is
at the foundation of our state
our people have never allowed their
freely expressed will
to be taken away from them
those who tried were always met with
failure
moldova today is guided and run by its
people
and they have consistently stopped
politicians who wanted to impose their
ill designs on the country
the freedom and the dignity of our
people
makes make us a country with a strong
european identity
which we deeply value
and our democracy and the freedom of
speech are becoming stronger
this year
reporters without borders ranked moldova
40th
out of 180 countries in the world press
freedom index that is 49 positions
better than last year
they cite changes initiated by the
government and improvements and the
situation of the journalists
we're working on consolidating
democratic processes we are taking
serious steps to make sure that all
political parties and the election
campaigns are financed legally and
transparently we are working on
countering this information and building
a strong and resilient civil society and
mass media
the people of moldova gave us a strong
mandate to reform the country and bring
it closer to the european union
today
like never before the government's
commitment to reform
institutions is unquestionable and
profound
we are well on course towards reforming
justice a too long overdue process
courts are becoming cleaner
prosecution more professional and
impartial we have eliminated a big
number of corruption schemes through
which the state and the people have been
robbed in the past
but building independent strong
institutions takes time
i'm asking for your help in tackling the
big corruption
i'm asking you to sanction the corrupt
politicians who captured institutions in
the past stole significant amounts of
public money and have moved abroad
investing the stolen money including in
countries with consolidated democracies
i'm asking you to help us recover the
stolen money and bring the corrupt
fugitives to justice
the eu states and institutions the
international community should do more
to reject the dirty money especially
the money the dirty money coming from
fragile democracies
history and our own transition
experience has taught us
that the sustainability of the
democratic achievements is closely
linked to economic development
a major challenge for us is to create
economic opportunities for everyone at
home
to convince our young people that it is
worth trying to build a future in
moldova
over the past nine months the government
and the parliament have been working
together to improve the business
environment
we are working with the business
community inside and outside of moldova
to demonstrate that moldova is changing
and becoming a better place for one to
build his or her future
we have increased support to smes and
launched dedicated programs for young
entrepreneurs
with your help we started building up
our energy security and resilience
we embarked on the reform of our
security sector we are strengthening our
border management capacity we are taking
steps to improve the efficiency of
public spending to improve coverage and
targeting of the social assistance
programs and to eliminate undeclared
work we're taking measures to improve
access to quality education and health
services
however despite our achievements
we've been hit hard by a succession of
crisis culminating with the war against
ukraine
the country's resources are
overstretched the social economic
situation is difficult the dramatic
increase in the energy prices is the
main reason for a historical surge in
inflation
27
the measures that we are taking to build
energy security will show results only
in a few years
investments have practically stopped
because of the war at our border supply
and chains have been interrupted
even though 76 percent of our trade is
with the european union an important
part was with ukraine belarus and russia
financing the shortfalls in revenue is
no simple task
the transmission conflict is another
challenge that the country is facing we
remain committed to a peaceful political
resolution of the transnational conflict
fully preserving moldova's sovereignty
and territorial integrity within our
internationally recognized borders
recent tensions inside the transnational
region however have increased concerns
of a political of a potential
destabilization
the moldovan government works hard to
keep the situation stable and peaceful
by pursuing a diplomatic track
of conflict resolution
and we will continue to do so for the
sake of our citizens on both banks of
the nisto river
we do not want war or destabilization
we have a vision for peaceful
reintegration of the country which will
guide our efforts to keep the situation
stable
we believe today there is no immediate
threat
of moldova being dragged into the war
moldova is also a neutral country by
constitution a provision still backed by
a majority of our citizens
which we respect
however to be really neutral we have
continuously called for the withdrawal
of russian troops from our territory
because their presence in the
transnistrian region fundamentally
violates our neutrality and our
independence
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen despite the long
list of overlapping challenges
that i just talked about
moldova is strongly determined to stay
part of the free world
we are part of europe
eu's values
eu's values are our values respect for
human life and the pursuit of everyone's
dreams in dignity and peace
as human beings
i ask you
to increase the youth support for
moldova for the sake of moldovans who
want to preserve their democracy and
freedom but also for the sake of europe
to have a stable predictable and
reliable partner and contributor to
peace
in its eastern neighborhood
at the same time
our independence
peaceful development
economic and political reforms
must have an anchor
and this anchor is a clear perspective
of eu accession the status of a
candidate country
in the middle of the dramatic events
myself the prime minister
the speaker of the parliament signed on
the 3rd of march the application for eu
membership
we made this choice
inspired by the aspirations of our
people
we chose eu accession as a path towards
freedom prosperity and peace
a path that will require
a lot of work coordination
and goodwill but one that is worth
every step
on may 12 we submitted the completed
comprehensive assessment which will
provide the basis for the european
commission to issue its opinion on
moldova's candidate status
this was a significant collective effort
on behalf of our small civil service
parliament civil society and our
diaspora abroad
we all worked hard because as a country
we believe
in the eu
in its values and in its bright future
we are aware that political decisions
at the eu level have to be made
we are also aware that these are not
easy decisions
but granting moldova candidate status
is the right decision
first i want to say this
we belong in the european union we are a
european country
with a european language a european
history and a european political system
at least one third of us are already eu
citizens
our big diaspora is among you you have
likely met us
we live
side by side with you we pay taxes and
contribute to
our share to the common good
we come from a diverse society with
different where different cultures have
coexisted in peace and harmony for
centuries
preferring compromise to confrontation
in this we are europeans
moldova's democracy is gradually
strengthening we are fully committed to
advancing reforms ensuring rule of law
and strengthening an independent and
corruption-free justice system
our economy and trade is increasingly
connected
and integrated into the european market
the eu is our main
trading and investment partner
very important for us
the eu is a peace project
the waves of the eu integration
transformed europe from a continent of
war to a continent of peace it embodies
the successful struggle for peace and
reconciliation for democracy and human
rights
we are not naive to believe that
eu accession can take place overnight
we understand that the accession process
is long and complicated
and we don't look for shortcuts
we deem accession as based on
meritocracy and achieved results
and not on geographic sequence
we fully respect the meritocratic
principle
at the same time we would like to see
pragmatism and strategic political
flexibility on behalf of the eu member
states
a prospect of accession would send to
modern citizens a strong signal
that the eu stands by us
for us
the eu membership status is the light at
the end of the tunnel in this very
difficult and uncertain times
a clear target
and a strong political message to
mobilize everyone society business
community
and authorities around the european
integration process
we need a political decision
that will be for moldova the lighthouse
in this terrible storms
guiding our country for years ahead
ladies and gentlemen here at the
european parliament i know i'm speaking
to people who are already convinced
this house is the consciousness of the
european people
it is the institution that represents
the people of europe
it provides a vision for europe
it is driving europe
and it is standing by us
and i'm
very grateful for your support
it is just days ago
that you members of the european
parliament
our friends and partners
have passed the resolution urging the eu
to grant moldova a candidate status
thank you for this on behalf of all
moldovans thank you for recognizing our
european choice and our hard work in
implementing reforms our constant fight
for democracy
we are asking for nothing more than to
live in peace
that our voices be heard and taken into
account
and to be guided in our affairs by the
will of our people
defending these values with your help
we will be able to build a prosperous
future for our citizens
i ask you to become moldova's
ambassadors in your countries
and call on policymakers to support
moldova and its past to stay part of the
free world by joining the world's most
successful peace project
i urge you to hear this strong message
from the moldovan people
the european union should once again
show that it is the world's most
successful union for advancing peace
prosperity and democracy
the eu has created the longest period of
peace in europe's history and it can do
it so again
extend this anchor of peace once again
to states
seeking safe harbor which truly merit
and believe in this thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much president sandu yeah
maya as you can see by the
reaction and the standing ovation of
this house we truly
thank you for your commitment your
vision and your leadership and we really
really we stand with you
dear friends we need we need to open uh
this mini plenary i have a few
announcements first of all
in consultation with the swedish and
belgian prime ministers i today
sent a letter to my counterpart mr
muhammad khalid speaker of the islamic
consultative assembly
of the my list on behalf of the european
parliament
i expressed our strong opposition
to the death sentence on professor
ahmad reza jalali
and his execution announced to take
place this saturday
[Applause]
[Music]